[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
pour une science ouverte
sous les effets de la révolution
numérique la diffusion des productions
scientifiques a été bouleversé
ainsi est né le projet d'une science
ouverte
il promeut l'idéal d'une diffusion large
immédiate et gratuite des publications
mais également des données de la
recherche
universités et instituts de recherche
accompagnent ces évolutions impulsant
même certains changements
saisie par la commission de la culture
du sénat l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques le texte adopté le 9 mars
2022 un rapport pour une science ouverte
réaliste et équilibrée et respectueuse
de la liberté académique
le texte a été présenté par le député
pierre en relais et les sénateurs laure
darcos et pierre aux oulias
tout en se prononçant en faveur de la
transparence de l'ouverture et du
partage des publications et des données
les rapporteurs estiment qu'il faut bien
peser les opportunités et les risques de
la science ouverte
par exemple ils déplorent l' hégémonie
programmée du modèle diamant qui
signifierait un risque de dépendance
accrue à l'égard de l'état avec des
revues qui fonctionnerait exclusivement
sur des subventions publiques
l'opecst sts plaide en faveur d'une
politique de science ouverte équilibrée
et concertée garantissant le pluralisme
de l'expression scientifique
cette politique nécessitera une
coordination interministérielle plus
poussées notamment entre le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation et le ministère de la
culture
pour encourager la bibliodiversité
l'opex tu préconises par exemple
d'assurer un soutien aux petits éditeurs
à cet égard l'office souligne
l'importance de garantir la liberté de
divulgation et de faire respecter le
droit d'auteur
le texte suggère en outre de prévoir des
formations aux enjeux de la science
ouverte dans tous les milieux de la
recherche
par ailleurs les auteurs du rapport
jugent utile de réviser les modalités
d'évaluation des chercheurs au profit de
critères plus qualitatifs afin de
réduire la pression à la publication
enfin les parlementaires rappellent que
la réflexion menée sur la science
ouverte ne sera pleinement fructueuse
qu'à condition de l'intégrer à une
réflexion plus large sur la crise du
monde de l'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]